George Mount: Thank you Rachael thanks everybody for coming as Rachael mentioned lines are open at any time, we want to get your questions answered, and they can be as Rachael mentioned anonymous or not,
George Mount: So let me kind of switch gears here and get to my slides okay all right, I will share some links to get my resources and everything in a moment as well,
George Mount: But if you want to let me know at the beginning again, we want to make this as conversational as possible, so let me know what brought you here today, what have you tried what's worked what's not worked,
George Mount: I don't have all the answers on this, but we're all helping each other, so let, let us know,
George Mount: And again, we want to, and there will be an announcement later to help you continue on in this path,
George Mount: it's not the easiest thing to get a team who's used to using excel to kind of think the art of the possible and using R and see how possible, it is, I hope the presentation shows you how easy it is, and then we can take you to that next level to actually see that, through to your organization,
George Mount: Okay, so just for a little cold open, I want to really get it out of your head that R is necessarily harder than excel I think that's the word on the street, you do have to code it,
George Mount: But you have to code, a lot of things in excel as well, so i'm not sure that that's, the best thing to think about it as being necessarily harder,
George Mount: i've got a few other case studies like this and then we're going to move into a short DEMO and then we'll go,
George Mount: For questions i've also got a couple of books to give away so make sure that you stick around and you may get a copy of my book advancing an analytics if you don't want to copy,
George Mount: You get a consolation prize, you can read it for free, I will give you a link to do that so everybody's a winner with the book okay let's say you want to visualize a bunch of variables,
George Mount: This is how I see you would do it now again I could be wrong with these examples where i'm showing excel and are and how you do something, so let me know if there's another way because there's almost always another way it excel or are,
George Mount: But this is how I would do it let's say you know, I have a bunch of variables in my data set, and I want to see the relationships between all of them,
George Mount: Okay, this would be a lot of code it in excel right that's a lot this is literally three lines in R Okay, and this is a pretty nice thing to have you know you have data, you want to visualize it that's not a bad idea,
George Mount: lot easier to do an hour okay so we're going to do a few more examples of that but, again, just to give you a sense of what we're going to do,
George Mount: Really understanding how excel and R fit together and the analytic stack i'm not going to tell you to get rid of excel i'm not going to tell you that excel socks i'm not going to spread any lies about excel that often happen when people try to push other tools,
George Mount: we're going to introduce R for you kind of see how all these tools fit together, hopefully you'll have fun,
George Mount: I hope you're telling me that i'm having fun and I think Rachael is too we'll see you know, trying to get everybody else on board and then maybe like I said when a book or if you don't want to book, you can get the link for it for free so we're all winners on that,
George Mount: Okay, the first link is going to be here now, if you want to follow along and i'll put this in the chat as well, and then, if there's any place,
George Mount: That should be shared also we can we can get that circulated, but this is going to have all the resources and everything now i'm aware that a lot of people may be coming to this for the first time,
George Mount: In R they don't have it installed they can't get it installed because their work, etc,
George Mount: Just click this link, you can follow along and that will run it'll take a few minutes you'll be able to run everything that we're doing on the cloud,
George Mount: And then, when you read the book you'll learn how to download it and then we'll help you make the case to get it installed at work, hopefully Okay, so if there are any questions there, let me know i'm going to go back to the slides and we'll keep going here,
George Mount: My questions are welcome at any time okay i'm going to skip this slide this from the book just to situate all the various parts of excel again i'm telling you that,
George Mount: don't uninstall excel if you're here that's not my takeaway by any means alright so where's are going to help you,
George Mount: Now these are some things and if you've used R before if you're an excel user I just kind of boil this down into a few categories of tasks that I find really helpful if you're an excel user,
George Mount: where R can help now, the first thing i'm going to mention its power query it's kind of the elephant in the room that's, the first question, I often get,
George Mount: If you're using power query you're not in excel, let us know, but its power query is a data preparation data transformation tool,
George Mount: And excel and it can do a lot of the things that are can do to be honest, it can build a reproducible workflow,
George Mount: It can work with big data, so this thing about oh you can't do a million rows and excel past that,
George Mount: If you're using power query that's not necessarily true, and this is not an excel course per se, but just to know that power query does exist, but there's still things that are helpful,
George Mount: With excel so like data visualizations we saw you have a bunch of variables, you want to visualize them you and iterate on that,
George Mount: Are is going to help you there anything I found that we're working with groups where you have some data and you want to go through group by group and do some kind of trance complex transformation,
George Mount: I think about R for that again window functions kind of related to that cumulative averages lagging variable leading variables,
George Mount: you're going to see some examples where we're power query is kind of challenging for that and then anything having to do with randomization excel I recently learned that excels random number generator is proprietary,
George Mount: intentionally they have not shared how the random numbers are actually randomly generated for a reason,
George Mount: And that has proprietary benefits, but if you try to make your workflow reproducible that might not be a good thing if you want to see Duran of data so Those are just a few a few things that that would be helpful,
George Mount: So again, just to make this really concrete i'm going to create an index column by group now again if you have another way to do this and excel let me know this is the way that I found it's a lot of code it can't even fit on the slide,
George Mount: Are for four lines of code and it's pretty readable to right we're grouping by something we're going to take an index number that looks like it's based on the row,
George Mount: There, where i'm going to print the hat of it, I guess that's the first few rows right so that's pretty English sounding this is, I don't know I guess it's English, but I don't know what decompress binary is what the heck is that,
George Mount: So, again it's not necessarily easier, a creating a lag variable and other one you actually have to create your own custom function to do this as far as I know, and power query,
George Mount: In R somebody is already made that function for you that's Another thing we have packages and are there they're like Apps so but he's built a package, and you can use it and it's bundled the code,
George Mount: And then, that means that all I have to do is say Oh, I want to lag variable and you're seeing that these are all kind of the same pattern right and,
George Mount: The whole idea with what we're doing here and ours, these are really supposed to be predictable and when you're going to do something, it should follow kind of the same paradigm,
George Mount: Whereas you're seeing an excel kind of we've been all over the place already right we're using vba, if you remember to do,
George Mount: back here there's that and then we wanted to do this, and now looks a little different and now, this is a little different everything nothing's really,
George Mount: kind of syntactically matching and that's really a big thing of Rs, specifically with the Tigers talk about everything's kind of meant to be interchangeable part interchangeable parts,
George Mount: Okay,
George Mount: Do you get a profile,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'm on cool,
George Mount: So data profiling let's say you know you have missing data now power query has some ways to do that for us, but it's not necessarily things that you can code,
George Mount: Again, I want to be able to check my data check my Meta data be able to see what values are missing, how many columns I have,
George Mount: Your really work programmatically not just with the data, but with the data about the data and that's one thing that I find that excel and a lot of the bi tools,
George Mount: aren't really so great at even something like Oh, I have a database and I want to list all the tables in that database understand the schema it's not really any code generation that you can per se do,
George Mount: In a lot of these tools and then let's go, I think, a couple more examples here random data again,
George Mount: I mean what the heck's going on here I don't know because I can just do this in one line with our, and this is nice right, you have a big data site, you want to spot check,
George Mount: Right in this obviously if you're familiar with machine learning there's a lot of randomization that goes on there you gotta split your data all that stuff, not only is this really, really hard,
George Mount: But you can't see this randomly so that you know when your colleague, does the same simulation they're going to get the same results,
George Mount: And there's some ways around that in excel but by by default that random number generator and excel you can't you can't set a seat on,
George Mount: Okay uh this slide I think is good to really understand that learning are as an investment of your time, and you have a couple ways when you do something you can,
George Mount: hack it together manually and sometimes needs must and right, you need to get something done by the end of the day, you can hack it together and excel,
George Mount: But in the long run,
George Mount: you're going to save time and you're going to win right you spend all this time you're goofing around you're running scripts and it doesn't work and your colleagues or your boss your colleagues are thinking what the heck why can't they just get the report done,
George Mount: But Lo and behold, you get to that tipping point and everything's automated you don't have to do things manually anymore and you're out of that kind of,
George Mount: infinite loop, so to speak, of just coding things hacking together in excel and not to beat up on excel because that can happen in any program but R is going to have a lot of tools that are going to help you get out of that rut,
George Mount: Okay, so let's see how we're doing on time oh yeah one thing I want to do is a giveaway so we're about halfway through my,
George Mount: Formal remarks and then we can get to the questions soon uh we have a chat I believe I see a lot of comments so we'll make sure that we kind of get the conversation kicked off, I think the first thing i'm going to do,
George Mount: is OK, I see one from Ivan I did say that it is a it is sort of reproducible yes, I, I fully agree so yes okay,
George Mount: um I have, hopefully, nobody saw that I have a few data brain teasers so what i'm going to do is pull it up here on the screen,
George Mount: And the first person who types the right answer, and so this is going to be an image of some kind of data or statistical concept, if you get the answer,
George Mount: And you type it in the chat you'll get a copy of the book Okay, so in 321 this is going to go up on screen,
George Mount: and actually a little later than that but whoever gets this right just type it in the chat try to sound this out verbally and you get to work okay john all right, congratulations, we got a lot of people, maybe that was too easy,
George Mount: But john a send me a message,
George Mount: and
George Mount: You can get the copy of the book so congratulations Sean and again if you don't win don't worry, because you can still read it for free so it's not it's not the end of the world,
George Mount: Alright, so for the next 15 or so minutes, maybe less we're going to do and I don't know how much of this will get through, but I just want to show you a little example of of using our,
George Mount: to conduct some data analysis okay so i'm going to call this data baseball and i've split this into a few steps here okay so you'll find this will will navigate to this together in a minute, but the idea is let's say is major league baseball it's almost baseball season,
George Mount: I want to know is there a relationship between teams payroll and other variables right can we use the team payroll to understand how much they win,
George Mount: How many people attend right and if you're a data person, you may be thinking, these are dumb questions that's cool, but we can still start here right and and we'll look at how to do that,
George Mount: A few steps so we're going to import the data, think of this is the little game of baseball right bring in the data,
George Mount: we're going to do some basic data profiling, so how many rows how many columns how many tables, etc, that will analyze the data visualization I kind of call the shortstop here so we'll get to that,
George Mount: and generally with R and that's, I think, important to understand if you're an excel user your data generally isn't going to live in R you're,
George Mount: probably going to get it from some other place that could be a database or an API or an excel file or wherever right and then you'll do your working are,
George Mount: And then you're going to send it out now probably for a lot of you that might be sending out sending it out to excel so i'll show you a couple of ways to do that there, there are some options,
George Mount: If you wanted to you could fully automate your excel report and and do that from R you might not even probably have to open excel if you don't want to you, could you could do everything,
George Mount: In R OK so i'm going to go to here now, if you have the binder open you'll you'll see RStudio open and it'll look something like this,
George Mount: I think you'll go to files and you'll see this database ball, this is rmd for R markdown now if you're if you're familiar with,
George Mount: Mark down the idea is we're able to use plain text characters to to render taxed and you'll end up, and this is another cool thing to know you could bake a fully reproducible report here with with R and right this looks like something that you could share on the office no problem,
George Mount: Okay, so we're going to work through this and, again, just to be cognizant of time I may not go through this line by line, which is to show you kind of what R is what it does, etc okay So the first thing to understand is ronnie's a lot of packages,
George Mount: This think of these as like the Apps of R okay so,
George Mount: You gotta get a smartphone it's pretty cool and it's got some basic utilities, you can make calls and schedule appointments and stuff like that take notes etc really a lot of the power comes in,
George Mount: The Apps that you download from the APP store that let you do whatever special use case or help you do things a little more productively so that's going to be the same thing with with R right so we're going to download Apps,
George Mount: we're not going to get into the specifics of how you download them, you can read the book on that, but just for the mental model here you'll download the APP,
George Mount: you'll open that up to use it so you'll see that i've got all sorts of stuff that we're going to use here so,
George Mount: there's a lot of cool data that you can find a practice with in R which is alone, a really real blessing,
George Mount: The tidy verse I mentioned a timer to, so this is really a package of packages we're going to use that a lot,
George Mount: To create visualizations to model or data to do all those data analysis tasks,
George Mount: And then there's some other ones that i'm going to use just for maybe I really like a function that that happens to be in that package, a lot of different ways that that you can use it, and then to write to excel,
George Mount: which might be which might be helpful so you'll see that i'm running this,
George Mount: And everything's being generated down here in the console I do have in the book a brief tour of RStudio I will also say that RStudio has a lot of tremendous learning resources,
George Mount: And really the idea of of RStudios everything you need to do your job, and ours is here so there's a reason there's so many pains and windows, but now you'll get you'll get more familiar with it, I would definitely encourage you early and often to check the help window up here,
George Mount: There are some really great cheat sheets there's also a help tab over here, you can learn more about different functions packages things like that,
George Mount: So I would say that's another real nice benefit of using R it's just a really robust documentation and help specifically in RStudio,
George Mount: So we're doing that, we sent this down to the console now again this isn't a script and this isn't a markdown R markdown scripts so I can save this I can render it later if I want to to make a nice report that I can show around the office,
George Mount: So i'm going to bring in my data and let's see why okay there we go control shift enter, if you want to run these these chunks is going to be the keyboard shortcut I believe on windows MAC might be a little different,
George Mount: But now i'm going to start with,
George Mount: Selecting my data visualizing it all that kind of stuff it's all going to come down to profiling, the data now what's really nice with with our,
George Mount: And again, to be fair, someone mentioned power query to you, but,
George Mount: there's never going to be a need to like randomly delete data or hide columns or any of that messy business,
George Mount: That gets people in a lot of trouble everything's going to be programmatic So if I have a data set, and I only need four columns and you can almost kind of read it here,
George Mount: i'm not gonna i'm not gonna delete those other columns that's not a good idea, you want to keep your source data intact,
George Mount: Right and then you can make a copy of that and do what you want to from it and that's what i'm doing here i'm say Okay, I have a data set,
George Mount: i'm going to select a few columns i'm not going to hide them i'm not going to delete them or anything like that, and then this looks pretty nice to you, I mean aesthetics matter, and I think that Rmarkdown understands that okay so let's see i'm going to,
George Mount: visual are sorry i'm going to aggregate this data,
George Mount: Now, again, this is kind of like a pivot table I know somebody had mentioned in the comments about well how would I do something like a pivot table and in our,
George Mount: that's basically what i'm doing here so you're going to see, I have a salaries,
George Mount: table Okay, then you see this funny little icon here so basically what i'm doing you think of this as a pipe where,
George Mount: line by line by command i'm cascading my output into the next input, so I have salaries i'm going to group that by your ID and team ID so imagine a pivot table,
George Mount: And you're putting those in the Rose sections right, and then you need to aggregate it by something So these are kind of twin functions in a way, so i'm going to group that by then i'm going to say Okay, well, I want the total salary for each team, and then I can see what I have there,
George Mount: Okay, so that would be your pivot table, and now we can do is join them so again if you're using power query if you're using sequel,
George Mount: We have data different from different tables based on those relationships, you want to put them into one place,
George Mount: very easy to do here and in R specifically with the tidy verse and i'm going to use and enter join as you'll see,
George Mount: And I have emerged data set there, so now I have all the data that I need to conduct the analysis, again I don't know how much of it will get through,
George Mount: But all this stuff will stay up in perpetuity you want to run it hang around with it later you're welcome to do that,
George Mount: But I have my day my my teams, I have the variables, I want to check out so now i'm able to,
George Mount: Start iterating on on what i'd like to know about this data and hey maybe you thought oh actually I wanted to use these other variables well you didn't delete it so you're,
George Mount: you're welcome to just iterate on that script and you're not losing anything there Okay, and another thing just to know is that you can easily check like I said the metadata about your data,
George Mount: What Okay, in this case it's not really metadata but you're still able to see the sum of,
George Mount: One table versus another and easily easily compare it, I find that trying to do that kind of on the fly work and a lot of tools, I mean excels pretty good at it i'm thinking about things like power query power bi,
George Mount: they're not really meant to let you kind of on the fly analyses with with your data it's all based on that relational database and writing any kind of function can get messy pretty quickly with R everything saved in memory right so i'm able to just,
George Mount: call up anything write a function on it move on with my work and have this all saved in a script so that it's easily share easily reproduced and so forth okay so data profiling see how we're doing i'll give this a few more minutes and then we'll get to questions and all that,
George Mount: summary statistics also say ours are was really built for statistics, so you even look at,
George Mount: The official are they are the R project for statistical computing so a lot of the things that you want to do, related to statistics are going to be kind of built in now often you can augment those things with again these packages, depending on what you're looking for, but,
George Mount: Something like I want to get the summary statistics, there it is,
George Mount: A lot of data, a lot of packages help you like, I said augment that exploration so, for example,
George Mount: I like the skim package, this is from R skim R  functions from a package called skimmer i'll make this a little bit bigger,
George Mount: But again, you know you could get some of these things in the data profiler and power query,
George Mount: But it's not necessarily going to be something that I can just keep in my script and run to it there's going to be a lot of pointing and clicking I can't necessarily,
George Mount: easily share the output right, so in this case, I can see a lot of what I want to know about the data and things like missing values things like the distribution,
George Mount: Everything so you're really able to get a high level view of the data and then zoom in from there and work on what you want to with it okay,
George Mount: And I can move this back down a district, I like this describe function, this is from a package called site this just gives you a little bit more meat to those descriptive statistics, so if you want to know things like the range,
George Mount: The term to mean all that right, so a lot of options usually just like an excel there's almost always,
George Mount: Multiple ways to do something it's probably going to be the case and in R as well, so you can get to know your favorite packages share them and help them, you can even support them because,
George Mount: they're almost all going to be open source,
George Mount: they're taking contributors, so you can join that Community help with the documentation, as you get really good at, are you can, maybe even push push to the code base so it's pretty cool to know that all this stuff is being built by you right,
George Mount: Okay, so let's see what we'll do here, I know we've got a couple of minutes so data visualization is a great one to know i'm not going to get too much into into the syntax here,
George Mount: But one thing that I really want you to see is that if you have like a histogram and excel and you wanted to change it to I don't know tree map or a bar chart or something,
George Mount: It would be kind of hard, I think you have to change the chart type and sometimes your axes get messed up you want to switch the axes and,
George Mount: there's a lot of pointing and clicking it's hard to know exactly what happened up generally with with what we're doing here in GG plot, and this is another tidy verse package,
George Mount: You just have to change the function changing argument and that's Another thing I try to really point out to excel users you've used functions a lot right you've used index you've used the look up or X look up,
George Mount: you've you understand okay well this function this argument it's optional and this one is required, and this has a default,
George Mount: that's the same kind of stuff we're going to use a lot of functions in R so,
George Mount: You have like I said in the description, you have a big head start, and this thing may not really look like much right now, but if you break it down you're seeing okay,
George Mount: Well, I have a function and here's an argument data okay so that's probably where the data is coming from that makes sense,
George Mount: Okay, as that might not make as much sense right now but let's drill into that and we see okay X, so this is a chart Okay, so the access payroll that makes sense,
George Mount: And then I don't know about God, this is histograms so you're kind of okay so basically i'm making a histogram with payroll on the X axis from data,
George Mount: understandable and again if you wanted to change something it's very easy in this case I think i'm just changing my variable on the X axis Okay, so I think it's 1230 right now,
George Mount: Again you're welcome to run through any of this on your own the end product is going to be, and let me actually pull that up in my because I had already done this i'm,
George Mount: Okay, where is that file the joys of having a lot of windows open okay what I wanted to show you is the,
George Mount: output, that you could get let's say you wanted to use R and do all the cool things you learned today, but you still have to put it into excel because that's what people at work demand on,
George Mount: This could be and again there's the code for for this in that in that notebook and I don't know why it's so slow okay it's opening just on the other, window okay so,
George Mount: Here we go, so we have a table I wrote this from excel now i'm sorry from R now if you needed to maybe I don't know make this formatted and you know add the currency and all that you could do that and and,
George Mount: In R so if you're a v R ba person and you've worked with kind of programmatically formatting columns and things like that,
George Mount: You could add these charts now I put a chart from GG plot, you could build an excel chart from R as well, so again really anything you needed to do,
George Mount: To build some kind of excel product, you could do it and are, and this is just the tip of the iceberg right, so we only have so much time and you're saying that I already,
George Mount: didn't get to show you everything, but like I said, you can check it all out later Okay, so let me go back to the slides here I think we'll do a giveaway in a minute here,
George Mount: um okay The other thing and i'll make sure that this gets and then it will move to the questions and discussion and everything,
George Mount: If you want to summarize what you've learned today this is going to be a White Paper that I have is just a few pages, just to learn about R as an excel user,
George Mount: So you can download that White Paper from from my website and and we'll get you sign up we'll get that sent out to you quickly Okay, so let me go to questions I think Okay, I think this is good um yeah let's,
George Mount: Look,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Both questions,
George Mount: yeah that would be great,
George Mount: yeah and then we can give away in a bit too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome Thank you and I see a few people I put questions into the chat but just a reminder, you can use slide oh as well to either asked anonymously or put your name it's just easy to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): see them all there and organize them, but I see Gustavo asked a question one barrier found was translating terms from excel to our, for example, what's the equivalent of a data frame and excel it'd be nice to have a kind of like a dictionary or glossary of terms,
George Mount: yeah it would be good to have a have that all summarized I do, I mean that's really a foundation of the book is to translate those structures and functions from excel and to R and,
George Mount: that's the way we learn things is to associate what we already know with things that we're learning now so it's cool that you Gustavo are thinking in that way that's going to make things a lot quicker now as far as a,
George Mount: cheat sheet or something like that that's good abby get added to my to do list imminently here, however, I will say that the book does,
George Mount: Talk about that right what What would it vector look like in excel or vice versa um What do you do with a pivot table in R and so forth, so so that that's a good question with kind of an answer it's just not as condensed as as you might be looking for,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): yeah and if anybody has other resources to or things that you've found helpful feel free to put them into the chat too I see mark here at lunch i'm going to turn it on so people that unmute themselves,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay there there we go I see, mark you mentioned for people who primary use excel to present tables the GT package really helps do you want to add anything there,
Rieke, Mark: yeah sure I was just gonna say I think that,
Rieke, Mark: there's a lot of use cases for using R that go beyond just data analysis, you know just speeding things up and making your life easier,
Rieke, Mark: In other areas and in GT is a good example of that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome Thank you Jacob, I see you had your hand raised earlier, do you want to jump in with a question,
Jacob Mazalale: No,
Jacob Mazalale: Worries Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay, no worries,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome I see,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): McKee Stewart you had asked a question into the chat would you want to jump in and and so,
McKee Stewart: Sure, one of the questions I had it just as a novice playing around with R is that there's an enormous number of packages, it is, I am struggling with finding,
McKee Stewart: Which ones I need and how to look for a function if I if it's not in a package have already got,
McKee Stewart: Does that make sense, it seems overwhelming somebody pointed me in the chat to like the CRAN web page,
McKee Stewart: And that's good,
McKee Stewart: I can see where you would somebody would find that helpful but it's still too,
McKee Stewart: abstract,
Ryan Garnett: 20,000 packages yeah it's hard,
McKee Stewart: yeah so that's my,
McKee Stewart: thought for the day,
George Mount: yeah um,
George Mount: Is there a key any particular area,
George Mount: That you're looking to do a domain or a use case or something like that that might be the first place to start,
McKee Stewart: Mostly looking at that financial applications George,
George Mount: Okay cool so um are has a pretty sizable number of time series related things I would say that a lot of the lot of the packages and functionality, are going to be built off of some of the the tools used in in the book so like the first thing would be going back to RStudio,
George Mount: The help menu here check out these cheat sheets and get familiar with some of these maybe not all but,
George Mount: dplyr part two right so just learning the fundamentals because there's definitely going to be a power curve and like even in even in my script,
George Mount: Most of these probably 80% of these functions are coming from the same,
George Mount: I don't know through two or three or four packages and then there's like oh hey I really like this function and i'm going to call in this package,
George Mount: It could be a little dangerous to do that because it's just more bloat to your script but um yeah like get get really good at at probably a handful of them now, the TRAN task queues are good, but they are maybe overwhelming because there's so many of them,
George Mount: But yeah get get familiar with with these basic ones like the tidy verse right and that's actually more than one package,
George Mount: And then from there, I would say, you can start to specialize in and i'm sure RStudio has some resources for finance,
George Mount: But, but that would be my kind of loose recommendation and then, if anybody has other ideas on what to do with that and we're happy to hear that too thanks for the question yeah,
McKee Stewart: No thanks George,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see a lot of great links being shared in the chat too, and I can collect those together, but I feel you on that sometimes there's also so many different ways to do the same thing as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I I think something that has been most helpful for me, is when i'm actually googling how do I do this, and I see the packages that other people were using for that, too, but right Ryan, I see your hands raised to you want to jump in,
Ryan Garnett: yeah, I just wanted to add a feel your pain,
Ryan Garnett: My R journey started in 2018 when I decided for my first new year's resolution in my life I was going to stop using excel,
Ryan Garnett: or Google sheets, because I saw them as the same and only do stuff in R so it's really hard,
Ryan Garnett: To go there fast forward four or five years later, I think I would look at it differently, rather than trying to solve find the technology to solve the problem,
Ryan Garnett: what's the problem you're trying to do in R I think you can think of it as broken out into different kinds of steps so there's always you're going to use packages to bring in data,
Ryan Garnett: So that would be like a step right your this your financial questions is no good unless you can bring stuff in, so there are definitely some great packages around that,
Ryan Garnett: get to know read R again this comes from tidy verse so read rei Dr and then there's also,
Ryan Garnett: Read XL for excel stuff seeing how we're in here like those are two great sources there's other things if you're connecting to databases and like, if you think of it that way, like that's there,
Ryan Garnett: Like George was saying D player is going to be your best friend that's your that's your toolbox, it has your wrenches your hammers for cleaning up stuff,
Ryan Garnett: you're going to do a whole bunch of manipulation in there, that would be your package and then tidy are would be another one for cleaning,
Ryan Garnett: And then, depending on the analysis right so that's step one step two is like connect,
Ryan Garnett: Doing clean in the in the data world we call that wrangling are managing like cleaning up kind of stuff your room in your your dustpan and then there's the analysis kind of point,
Ryan Garnett: And like George said ours got a ton of financial stuff in there lots and then you have your visualization and then you have your output, so if you break it into like four or five sections connect,
Ryan Garnett: Cleaning wrangling analysis output, then it's a little bit less daunting to go through 20,000 packages on CRAN plus the Internet of like everyone's hosted github once,
Ryan Garnett: not sure if that helped or if you're like yeah thanks I kind of already done that, but like that's how i've kind of stepped through my thought patterns what am I trying to do in this section, rather than what are all the packages that I need to learn,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you Ryan that's really helpful,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see there's a few other anonymous questions inside Oh, I want to make sure I get to as well, and one is excel is reactive so, for example, output is automatically updated when input changes well R is generally not accept the shiny, how do you explain this to excel users,
George Mount: Okay um,
George Mount: yeah,
George Mount: When you have R and and you're you're storing the way I generally demonstrated, is that you in excel like like was mentioned you, you make one change and everything triggers so i'll just open up a spreadsheet and make one reference point to another point to,
George Mount: Another and then change the first one, and you see everything trickle down,
George Mount: And I think everybody has a horror story of,
George Mount: That going wrong,
George Mount: So I don't have to,
George Mount: really do,
George Mount: Too much convincing there, whereas in R all generally,
George Mount: Just store a couple of items as objects and and pretend pretend that we're putting each of these into a box and we're naming this box,
George Mount: You know my object or my string or something like that, so this this object is in,
George Mount: Your computer's memory now it's tucked away it's a box that nobody's going to open unless you tell your computer to,
George Mount: And they're all kind of separate entities now so that I i'm not going to make one change here and it's going to randomly change some other object if you're,
George Mount: If I guess you can still do that give it, you know how computers, sometimes behave but that's the general idea is you're right that it's not the,
George Mount: Not the kind of spaghetti of all these references so so there's a good good question I have some of those examples think I have some box illustrations in the book as well, so so that might be cool to check out but yeah that is a key kind of mental model milestone for getting into this,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Exchange and there's another anonymous question that says, I would like to ask a hypothetical question can a person upscale and both are in Python simultaneously,
George Mount: Oh yeah so the big one,
George Mount: Okay, so, so the book The book talks about from a sort of Python and R Okay, although you will, if you read it ours to second section, right after excel,
George Mount: Because, in my opinion, and some people think differently, but I think ours, a little easier for excel people to to get into,
George Mount: Because like I said it was really built for statistics and data analysis everything in excel is built around rows and columns right,
George Mount: that the open it up, and there are rows and columns that you see and and R is kind of built the same way with that data frame that's been talked about a couple of times on Python not necessarily so much was was,
George Mount: built around the idea of rows and columns and that's not a problem that's not to knock Python or anything but it just takes a little bit more of,
George Mount: A setup to do that, so I think that R is probably easier for excel people now as far as the question about learning both,
George Mount: I would again suggest, depending on what you want, depending on your time, you know individual results may vary as I always like to say so they're really a lot lot of contingencies, but this idea of,
George Mount: The the mantle cross training right and if you're going to learn to do something in R try to see if you can refactor it into Python or vice versa,
George Mount: doing something in excel try to do it in Python or are so, so I think that kind of inner disciplinary if you will approach is great, but as far as how to diversify your learning portfolio it's like I said it's really an individual kind of question,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Give and I see Monaly and apologies if I pronounce your name wrong, you had asked a question earlier, would you want to jump in and ask live,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I can,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): add the question, I can ask the question but feel free to jump in and ask and add any more context, but the question was any recommendations on resources that teach stats using R as the tool,
George Mount: Okay um I like the modern dive book it's a nice introduction that's pretty compatible with with a lot of what we've covered today with R with R I do a little bit of stats teaching in in the book,
George Mount: But we start with excel just because people are familiar with that and then reproduce this so if anybody else has favorite resources for learning learning stats you're you're welcome to let us know, but I think that that modern side is a pretty good start for that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome is that is it modern dive calm,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I just,
George Mount: Think yeah,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): OK cool and I know a few people had asked me about the recording if you joined a bit later and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Yes, the recording will be shared, to the RStudio YouTube and i'll put it on the meetup page and linkedin and Twitter or wherever you found the meetup to and i'll try and go through the chat to save all these awesome links and recommendations that people have to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And, but just to go over to a few other questions from slide Oh, I see Gustavo you had a question about building the logic behind the code would you want to jump in and add some context to that question,
Gustavo: Can you hear me,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Yes, I can perfectly,
Gustavo: Thank you yeah I mean I you know I think sometimes,
Gustavo: You know, some sort of the beginning of my learning path with with switch into R and and I don't know if this is my my lack of of,
Gustavo: You know, having strong logic and I think i'm a logical person, but you know you know you have to kind of have when you're building the code,
Gustavo: You have to know what comes first and what comes after and then just sort of build in that structure in your code,
Gustavo: I think we're, for better or worse, where we're taught to to kind of react, I think, somebody said that earlier in excel you just kind of do things that you see and and you and you hate things that you the link things,
Gustavo: But you're not building a sequence that you, you know, like you, doing Indian coding,
Gustavo: And, and I think you know I don't know if someone you know explaining myself right, but I think there's there's a border of how you code and what comes first and after when you're trying to build your data, you know for analysis and I think that's where sometimes they get stuck,
George Mount: Okay yeah so um I think it was Ryan was talking about trying to break it into discrete steps is is helpful,
George Mount: If you're an excel user than getting familiar with with power query and seeing each of your stuffs again transformed into discrete,
George Mount: Things right that even the idea of extract transform and load right three distinct steps we're getting data from somewhere we're transforming it and then we're loading it somewhere else,
George Mount: there's always going to be iteration there's also a really cool if you read R for data science,
George Mount: there's that tidy workflow and some people in the audience, I know what i'm talking about where it shows you each of the steps, but then there's the part of the middle,
George Mount: Where you're modeling and you're visualizing and it's really meant to be iterative right but, but there is there is a sequence that you follow, but there is going to be some some give and take, there, so if anybody knows okay yeah Rachael thanks for that,
George Mount: So hopefully That was a little helpful,
Gustavo: Thank you cool thanks,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you all for the great questions too i'm looking over to slide Oh, and I see we've answered everything there, but I I know there's definitely things i've missed from the zoom chat with some of the comments so feel free to raise your hand to and jump in,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'm curious to hear from all of you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): where you are in your learning journey or also if you're starting to maybe help teach other people across your team what has worked best for you all to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): know a few people are just getting started, even today, with joining this talk so it may be helpful to also,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): share with each other what has worked best for just getting started and resources that were most helpful for you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): It sounds like having that glossary of excel to R terms would be really useful for us all, I see a few people had mentioned that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): yeah good point to start working on a real work problem,
Ryan Garnett: can be really helpful to,
Do,
Ryan Garnett: What I found like looking back at my own thoughts and then also like this past year, where i've been teaching people in R organization is,
Ryan Garnett: No offense to anyone with a moat say most R journey seem to be very linear,
Ryan Garnett: start here and here and you'll be perfect and that's just how it works, and you know everyone has 10 hours a day to learn that, like we like we did in,
Ryan Garnett: High School and undergrad and stuff like that, whereas in the workforce you're trying to solve a little tiny problem, and it seems ginormous,
Ryan Garnett: Like it seems so big right like when you're first learning so breaking them down into real problems, and it could be like I, I just want to know how to open our,
Ryan Garnett: read in a piece of data,
Ryan Garnett: Right like so you know we're supposed to do this, get into functions and all those pieces but breaking them down into small little things that you're trying to do, and not trying to,
Ryan Garnett: have a goal of i'm going to be a superstar or i'm going to wear a Cape that has a big car on the back of it that's you know, there are some of those people in the world, I think we know those names,
Ryan Garnett: But do we all profess to want to be that I think it's being able to be really comfortable and efficient within your own pieces so breaking it down that way, so in work like what are you trying to do,
Ryan Garnett: Well i'm trying to bring in this data and like change the name, so that they're all capitals,
Ryan Garnett: Or, I want to calculate the average the mean the Max or I want to see a relationship those little pieces and breaking them into module little goals is really helpful and,
Ryan Garnett: For me, when i'm teaching I try to not use any jargon any actual names of stuff because that can be a barrier until people's confidence comes up and then with confidence, they get the capability and then they're okay to use terms,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): it's really helpful ran and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Also, just thinking about,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Like what is that first big win for you or like a project that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): You maybe can save a bunch of time, once you actually get to doing it in R automating something,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And i'm wondering if people could share maybe what those are for them, or what are the areas or certain projects that you'd recommend, starting with,
McKee Stewart: Oh, have a particular recommendation we're a start, but it most of my roles typically i'd be doing all this up i'll work and SQL,
McKee Stewart: And then pushing it down to excel so in in that environment,
McKee Stewart: Is a self top person you figured out how to do something and it's important to build up a bunch of little chunks like that,
McKee Stewart: That you remember Oh yes, one time I had to do this, and it was in this job stream and then I can go there, get and say Aha I remember now so building a bunch of little chunks of stuff,
McKee Stewart: That you know work and you could remember where you put them to go back and refer to again will speed the process,
McKee Stewart: So it's kind of like where I am now, it says i'm just getting started so let's see where this goes thanks,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Definitely that that's a really good point like, besides being able to reuse your own code and being able to find it it's very important to,
Oh,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see someone else said in to the chat any regular reporting, especially if the reporting requires copying paste,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'm going through that right now with making,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Trying to make slides with R so that i'm not copying and pasting into Google slides so that every time the data updates I can just automatically update the slides,
George Mount: yeah good call out you, you can make a slideshow with with R and the tools that we're using today I didn't do that because,
George Mount: it's that trade off and sometimes don't kill yourself right there's always going to be a trade off if you just have to do things once maybe,
George Mount: The sloppy way is okay right it's okay to make powerpoints depending on what you're doing if you have a case like with Rachael where the data is going to update and you don't want things to break in that then it's probably a good idea,
George Mount: If you have to copy and paste like somebody mentioned that yeah think about automating it but, but you know, sometimes I think we as tech people want to just automate everything and that's a good that's a good instinct to have, but it can it can backfire at times let's be honest so,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So definitely taking a lot longer but i'm hoping it's worth it,
George Mount: Oh yeah yeah no it's a it's an awesome tool to,
George Mount: Have and even I i've had i've had things where you know people have their weekly reporting and they're copying and pasting out of excel and,
George Mount: Dumping it into an email or a PDF or whatever, and just I think it's that art of the possible to write just knowing that you can automate it even if you don't know how to yet,
George Mount: Just knowing that you can and having the aspirations to doing it already puts you ahead of the majority of your cohort so that's great,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see Jamaica had a great idea in the chat and you said you'd love to partner with individuals to work on small projects and build on real world projects to build your portfolio,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And it looks like quite a few people are interested in that too i'm trying to think what's the best way for us all to connect here,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): After the fact, and I was Pedro just read my mind do that's great the R for data science slack channel is a great resource,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So maybe we can make a channel there to follow up from the meetup and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Just to make it easy to find after the fact, or call it excel meetup i'll reach out to john who runs that that group, but if anyone's interested in joining that slack it's i'll put the link to join in the chat,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But also before we hit the top of the hour, I also wanted to introduce the new working group that we'd like to kick off,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And for that i'd love to turn it over to you Ryan, to introduce it,
Ryan Garnett: Thanks Rachael it just took me a long time to click those,
Ryan Garnett: Noise sorry Thank you everyone for for welcoming me and allowing me to be here and take a few minutes of your time,
Ryan Garnett: excel is the bane of my existence and everyone's existence it's actually where I learned to code like you said, George Ray like you, you learn functions and that kind of stuff that got me on that path
Ryan Garnett: I think the superhero in me wants to turn everyone into an hour user and i'm a fanboy and I see its power,
Ryan Garnett: But I do know a little bit of the reality that not every single user in my organization current or potentially future will probably share the same sentiment that I do so,
Ryan Garnett: Thinking through it and, like in other places what's the goal and in our organization and I hope the goal is to turn people into,
Ryan Garnett: Data users and using data to make informed decision making, so getting them to use it and the likelihood of removing excel is probably 20 plus years away like realistically in my organization and maybe even more than others, so,
Ryan Garnett: At another place at the city of Toronto We took that on and was like well let's have people go where they're comfortable and we made something for Google sheets and that's where i'm talking,
Ryan Garnett: want to go to us, knowing that excel is a big part of many people's data life, maybe not individually, but organizationally,
Ryan Garnett: I would love to make an have something that allows people to gain the power of R with inside of excel realistically what could that be,
Ryan Garnett: we've been playing with it and creating api's and hosting them and connect so that people can pull data rate into excel,
Ryan Garnett: So that some of that stuff is already taken out of the out of the equation, and then also maybe accessing different models right So if you have models, but currently today it's kind of a pain right, you have to,
Ryan Garnett: write Vb macros,
Ryan Garnett: And all these other things to link up to API so my thought was,
Ryan Garnett: Is there a chance or desire a thought that people would love to collaborate work on building an ad in that connects up where people connect to data sources for their organization and pull it in whether you have,
Ryan Garnett: Sorry for the shameless plug or connect or or another source of where you host your data,
Ryan Garnett: So love to chat about it, I don't know if that was what you're thinking Rachael but like these are some of the thoughts to really push R and help out that transition to a data organization and maybe another step for users to jump into the world,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Definitely and curious to hear other people's thoughts to this, I know, also Ryan, when we talked about it, I mentioned,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): doesn't have to be someone who you uses R everyday if you use excel every day we want to hear your perspectives to around what would be useful,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So I did just put a link into the chat right now, if you'd want to be part of that working group, you can kind of you can just put your email and name in there and we can schedule a smaller zoom meeting to just chat about it, to see what works best,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But this is always the hard part silence on here, to see if somebody wants to jump in but feel free if you have other thoughts to or,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): One to expand on anything Ryan said,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But, again, I put that form right there, and if you want to join that that next call feel free to just put your email in there,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I know we're getting to the top of the hour and a few people mentioned, they have to run,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I do want to make sure we also get to all the questions that you had for George too, and thank you so much, George for an awesome presentation really appreciate your time here and sharing with all of us,
George Mount: jury how love to see the people making connections want to start a group all that stuff so uh that's great to see the Community starting already within an hour,
George Mount: I did want to do, I picked a get another winner,
George Mount: So, Michelle C congratulations you win a copy of advancing an analytics So if you want to let me put my,
George Mount: Let me put my now and,
George Mount: again,
George Mount: And just send me a note and we'll get that sent to you and the other thing is just for my kind of wrap up here,
George Mount: i'll put this in the in the chat as well if you did win a copy don't fear, because you can still you can still read the book, yes, Francis it is available, you can learn a lot more about the book The chapters where to get it, and so forth at this link,
George Mount: i'm Amazon wherever you buy a book, you can read it from the publishers website you'll find a link to read it for free so happy reading and, if you could please leave a review right because that lets people know of its quality,
George Mount: it's again the Community helping each other, so all I can ask for having attended today is, if you choose to read the book leave a review and and i'll feel like we've had a pretty nice Community building session here, so I think that's everything from me and i'm happy to,
George Mount: answer any more questions you can find me on LinkedIn if you'd like i'll put my know on in the chat there as well,
George Mount: i've got the website as well, you can check that out where the book is and yeah thanks again everybody, I really, really appreciate everybody's time and interest in the topic,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much, George i'm going to stop the recording now if anybody wants to jump in with other questions and just kind of makes the conversation,